so at TGS they are showing off resident
evil revelations to this is the first
time they've actually ever showed it off
it's the sequel to the original which
came out last year it started out on 3ds
and then it was ported to pc and all
sorts of consoles so in the sequel
because we both got to play it I'm
curious is if you think it's pretty much
along the lines of the revelation series
well okay there are a lot of changes but
yeah first and foremost revelation
series is kind of set up as this more
like a straightforward and simple
approach to resident evil and compare
that to something like resident evil 6
which sort of implemented all these like
various melee attacks and these really
complex systems are like really
action-oriented and like this game has
some of that but it's much closer to the
original resident evil and like maybe
like the first three or four titles in
the series run back to Claire Redfield
and we're joined by mortal Burton who is
the daughter of Barry Burton he was the
sort of like was it the father figure he
was kind of like the old veteran in the
original Resident Evil game you know
Claire is sort of like the professional
like she's been doing this for a long
time and he's to wake up in his cell
like they're at a party and someone like
abducted them they wake up in the cell
and they have no idea what's going on
there's people screaming those crazy
[ __ ] happening Claire is pretty cool and
collected she's like been through this
sort of thing before Laura isn't
necessarily scared but she's definitely
more like reactionary and like like for
example she uses like really vulgar
terms for things like what macaque was
that the subtitle reads with like all
capital letter is it skinny even if
you're vulgar like that's such an
obscure phrase to use I wonder like that
will actually stay in the final version
it's a very weird dialogue for her to
use and I actually kind of found her a
little off-putting when I played it like
Mars character was what's constantly
like oh no I don't use guns not after
the incident and it was a very like she
was she's an interesting character will
see where they go with her but I mean at
this stage she definitely is high
contrast to the character you play the
game play is still symbol but her
characterization is over the top which I
think that's risen evil should never be
over the top like it always is best
unless we're talking about Wes here but
now this series is always best when it
kind of key it maintains it even tone
but one of the interesting things are
doing with the game
leasing an episodic for the original
revelations had this sort of built-in
episodic format but his released at once
and it was made that way because it's a
portable game you're only going to spend
so much time playing it per day so it
was a really good way to kind of divvy
up the game this time they're
distributing it chapter a week I believe
and it's about two and a half hours per
chapter which is pretty interesting way
to do it they were saying that like this
is a really good way to like give people
cliffhangers and sort of get them you
know like doing a water-cooler chitchat
like talking about like oh boy we think
something happened next yeah it's it's
paid off for a few other developers see
like how the episodic format plays out
and something else I want to ask you
about are those weird creepy monsters in
this one yeah they've done something
kind of a little creepier with the five
you're kind of like stuck in this kind
of looks like a cell type place it's in
the island is weird facility yeah and
these large monsters are kind of coming
out but they're humanoid like they look
like a version of human they are you so
they're they're known as the afflicted
like essentially like this if this
facility seems like it's a place where
people are being somehow changed from
standard people into these really
violent aggressive things known as the
afflicted and talking to the director of
the game they're not zombies it's not a
virus that you can spread so it's not
like one of them gets it and like it
pass it on it's um it's some other thing
and I'm kind of wondering like how it
works you know like this is other
mechanic where you wear like this
wristband and it sort of displays the
characters fear levels they hinted
towards it a little bit didn't they were
there saying oh we can we can see your
fear level on it it gets to a red or
colored based on your fear and it seems
like it's possible that that has an
impact on possibly how you become but
hasn't been proven or said yeah and I
asked them for more details and you
really wouldn't get into it an
interesting notice I asked him you know
Clara's back berry Birds daughter is
back where we gonna see any other
characters from the series make a return
and you know a little smile and chuckle
what spoil anything but yeah I think
fans of the series will be pleased with
what we do
so yeah I mean there's a lot to look
forward to i I think Morgan Monroe is
going to be a lot for people to kind of
get over but you know I don't think she
necessarily ruins again I think will be
pretty interesting to see how it works
out and you know it adds a co-op element
which really wasn't in Revelations
personal it's sort of some net was in
five and six so we'll see how that works
out it could be pretty good I guess
we'll have to see
you
you